paid communities interest me because i
came across this thing called tiger 21
and this sounds like lame that i'm
bringing this up now after selling the
company but i've been interested in this
for
for years um do you know what tiger 21
is
i've heard about it what i know about it
is it's kind of like
a mastermind peer group thing but it's
for a certain
wealth level i don't know if there's a i
don't know if there's an actual cutoff
but it's supposed to be for wealthier
and i think it's mostly older people and
uh we have a couple friends who are in
it so i i texted one of them today about
it so i got a little bit of info but
tell me what i missed what do you know
about it okay so tiger21
uh google it i don't know the url maybe.
maybe just that.com
um but basically it's a peer group where
you have to have at least 10 million
dollars of investable assets in order to
join
it's very expensive it's 30 000 a year i
wouldn't call it a mastermind
because mastermind has a certain
connotation but yeah it kind of is that
um i logged on to the site i i'm not a
member but uh i used a friend's
login to check it out and there's uh
at least 850 members according to the
what i saw
and according to their site so what's
that map 24 million dollars a year in
revenue
um they have local chapters that meet up
uh i guess now digitally and they do
things like they share
one another's portfolio and you have to
defend your portfolio
and so it's basically rooted in rich
people
talking about rich people stuff mainly
being investing but i think it turns
into a little bit of therapy every once
in a while like a lot of groups do
but what did your buddy say all right so
i texted uh our mutual friend
keith um and he's
he's uh he's a real estate guy he's been
on the pod you can go listen to keith's
episode
and keith's a good dude and he goes i go
you're in tiger21 right and he goes yes
um what's up and i basically asked him
what do you think about it
he's like it's an interesting group it's
because it's all about investing
preserving wealth
uh it's mainly for older people and um
he goes the typical meeting goes four
hours
you do like you said a portfolio defense
where you talk about what you're holding
and why
and other people get interested in it
and sometimes there's speakers
um sometimes it's sometimes an external
speaker
sometimes it's somebody from the group
who speaks and there's like a moderator
and they also do like events because if
you go to the website you can see like
they hosted a tiger 21 event at magic
johnson's house and so they're
definitely trying to build this kind of
like
who's who network this sort of like soho
club
soho house vibe uh to the whole thing
and it uh yeah so they do that they also
you get like deals so a friend of mine
sent me a deal where they
basically when you're wealthy you get
this thing called umbrella insurance
which you paid two grand a year and it's
just like
general insurance and it's basically the
story they tell you
is like if you get in a car crash and
someone googles you they're gonna see
you're rich and they're gonna want to
see you for five million dollars and
this protects against
all types of stuff and so they give you
a discount on
umbrella insurance um and so by my
calculation i actually would bet they do
30 to 40 million in revenue
and they recently sold to private equity
and so it's a relatively big business
and i actually read
about uh read up on it and someone said
like there's 90
retention rate which is pretty amazing
i've also been following reddit's
fat fire which is a subreddit similar to
this
and it's like tripled over the last year
so this space has got me incredibly
interested
but this is just one example of a paid
community and so what i wanted to do was
go through a few other paid communities
that are interesting i want to explain
i'm going to try to explain why i think
they work and then where the opportunity
is for other paid communities
can i start can i start with one
opportunity which is why isn't this just
a business model for our podcast
like why aren't we starting tiger 21 for
people that are you know that have
let's call it a million dollars of
investable assets so a million dollars
of sort of like liquid net worth
that you can go invest into something
and uh why aren't we starting this now
this seems like the perfect thing to do
for a podcast like this
i think that probably there should be
something like this i agree
if you go to the tiger21 website um
you'll see like
you know the type of models that people
use on their website is like their ideal
customer and it's like
65 year old white dudes who
own insurance companies that are quite
wealthy but not
young or not like our kind of
crew um so i agree i think there's
something there
okay so fair enough so let's go into it
all right
so let's talk about where should we
start i've done a bunch of research um
how about we talk about by the way
sorry sorry interrupt you one more time
the thing i just said by the way i think
is important
uh i said why isn't that the business
model for this podcast
i think way too many podcasts try to
just do ads
and we've talked in the past about like
super cast which lets you do like a paid
a paid kind of super premium version of
it for your hardcore fans who pay you
nine bucks a month or five bucks a month
or whatever and uh
you know i started a rolling fund
largely off of
the audience from this thing that said
hey i've listened to this guy a bunch i
trust him
he's he has a good track record and so
now that rolling fund is four million
dollars a year that i get to invest into
startups
that's more value than all of the ad
revenue that we had
before um and so i think that more
people should figure out
business models that are different from
the content that they're creating
and so i'm surprised more podcasts don't
have different business models i agree
with you
but we are working we're in one of the
most
lucrative niches there is i mean like if
you're
a comedian if you're um what's that
called the two women who talk about sex
all the time
call her daddy yes like that's a little
bit different so how do you make money
off that that's a little bit different
and that's actually what we're going to
talk about with paid communities so
let's actually talk about let's and i'm
going to bring that up so let's talk
about
what makes them interesting and what
makes them not interesting so to me what
makes them interesting
is that they can grow pretty quickly so
you had a podcast um you do this four
million dollar fund
now building the audience takes a while
but you turned your fun on and you
it was four million dollars in a matter
of months very quickly
so they seem relatively fast to grow
they're really fast if you have an
audience
but compared to like a software company
which would take 10 years i think we
definitely could build it
in a matter of two or three years second
they seem pretty fun to run if the
interest of your community is the same
interest that you have
if you if you if they don't then it's
definitely not as fun
but it's kind of interesting if you are
very interesting about what you care
about
third you don't really need a lot of
money to start one you kind of actually
need no money you really could just
start with a paid
facebook group um and you could have a
really lean team to do it
and finally they definitely seem pretty
profitable because you can have a lean
team but let's talk about the cons
one and this is what i've learned with
our paid stuff
and from friends i think churn could be
pretty high did you notice that churn
was high in any paid communities you've
been part of
honestly the churn was not high in the
paid community that i ran
um i don't measure the year yeah yeah
for sure but i was
it was a monthly it was a monthly fee so
you could churn out monthly right for
trends i think you charge annually
so you don't know your churn until you
know sort of later unless somebody
actively
cancels so it's not like uh like
enterprise software
return where it's like a net like a 100
negative yeah so that that i don't think
that exists in most communities by the
way my
my paid community just for real numbers
mine was seven percent a month was
churning which is
like if you just if you're not adding
any new members you know that doesn't
take long for it to go to zero
but i think seven percent is one year
no i'm talking about monthly i was
monthly i was churning
seven percent and so uh so oh you're
saying one year for it to go to zero
yes i think if you have a i think if you
have a four percent churn that's 18
months
and and so when with including my growth
i think my net
churn was like one percent so i think i
was adding six percent
and i was losing seven percent basically
every month and um
can you share anything about trends what
was the retention like
yeah um so we had some payment issues
when we first launched
so basically we had some issues um where
if someone signs up
on day one and on day 366 they get a
renewal
um the credit card statements a lot of
the banks will be like whoa whoa whoa
what's this that's fraud
so we actually had a big fraud a problem
with banks blocking it but 80
of people uh were opted in to uh renew
in the year one or in renew in year two
in our first cohort
yeah um ballpark ballpark about 80 which
is pretty good
but not but like it's hard to get new
customers on a consistent basis
yep um okay so uh the second thing is
a lot of times they don't scale that
well and the reason they don't scale
that well is if your community is kind
of like trends
where you value close-knit connections
or tiger 21
more people makes it actually worse um
now if your community is content based
which we're going to talk about in a
second
it can actually make it way better but
a lot of communities like a ypo like or
um
like if there's 150 people at your
meeting versus five people at your
meeting
one is worse than the other the scale
gets worse for two reasons one is
exclusivity so if the reason to be in
this group was that it's exclusive the
more people in the less exclusive it is
or the if the value is that oh i really
like this conversation this conversation
was really
really nice but now you get a noisy room
of a thousand people
well now it's just too noisy i can't
keep up with this i don't know who these
people are
some of these people are saying stupid
things i'm out of here right so that's
the two reasons that the scale
scalability hurts
yes and it can work though because if
you're a reddit which is a community
not a paid community but it's a good
community um you want more you need more
you need way way more people if you
are um quora you need way more people
if you're some of the other examples
that you need you need way more
more people is good and that's great um
but it's not always good to add more
people so
what i want to talk about is a few
communities that i found that i think
are interesting and then i want to talk
about
opportunities in the space and then
finally we can talk about what i think
you need to build a successful community
um so the first one that i discovered
and i've actually brought up here a ton
it's called aventa have you seen aventa
no
okay so eventa i know the first example
is gonna it's
like doesn't even entirely apply because
i think aventa is actually a free
community
but you need to apply and eat or get
invited so it's
somewhat similar but eventa is a
community is a professional group
um i believe it has uh 18 000
participating
members and it's for executives
particularly uh are you on the website
right now
no i'm on our our notes okay uh
basically it's for fortune 500 or
fortune 100 people
um it's people like the i don't even
like because i've never worked at a
company i don't even understand all
these roles but like a cio
was that a chief information officer so
uh i said c s o i'm looking at their
website
um c-i-s-o i don't even i don't know
what c-i-s-o means it was that chief
information security officer
yeah cso yeah so these are like
things that i don't even know i guess
they have cfo i know that is chief
financial officer so it's basically
executive
he's just turned into a glossary section
for
him to figure out well you know what
that really hro is
yeah that's basically your hr chief hr
officer basically okay i guess that one
was easy
a cdo i don't know that one
chief data management officer because
come on
a lot of people aren't going to know
what this stuff is but it's a big thing
they have 18 000 members and check this
out
they sold in 2016
for close to 300 million dollars it was
375 million dollars they sold for
and it was for 12 times profit which
means their profit was 23 million
dollars a year and almost all of that
profit
came from sponsorships and so the way it
works is is that uh
they would get groups of 10 or 20 people
they would host a talk
uh like i think it was mostly an online
talk that says like
how walmart is going to handle
how walmart is going to promote work
remote work
and 10 people like i'm just going to
guess
what's a fortune 500 so like the cmo of
northern
i'm looking at now the chief information
officer of northern trust i don't know
what that is but it sounds like a huge
company
uh the cio of um delta of chevron of
nestle is going to go which is like
it's only 10 people at that talk but
it's 10 people who each control
20 000 people and sponsors will
pay stupid amounts of money hundreds of
thousands of dollars to reach these
people enough that it makes
25 million dollars a year in profit uh
very interesting an interesting
community again
like tiger 21 if you go to the website
it just
kind of looks like pretty old school
mostly
older white people so who knows if it's
if it's hip or
or at least like in the know of
everything the second one that i want to
bring up and i got
hold of their deck uh a year ago and i
could have invested into it
and i skipped it i passed and i think
that might have been a mistake but it's
called soul savvy have you heard of soul
savvy
it's like a shoe thing yeah it's pretty
interesting
a sneaker head lover community something
like that yeah so it costs 33
a month and you basically when when i
was
got their deck it was basically just a
slack group that's all it was
and i don't know if that's what it is
anymore but there's a lot of kids
probably grown people as well who are uh
want to get insider tips on when a
certain drop of a shoe is
and they somehow game the system like
it's it's called
cook groups so there's these like groups
where they team up and somehow i i don't
know anything about the space but
they somehow get insider information on
when a drop is gonna happen and they
and they collaborate and scheme together
on how they can get access to these
certain shoes
now what soul savvy's doing is they
started with shoes it was just a slack
group which i think is
stupid by the way i think if you're
building one of these on slack group
that's not the right move
but they get they get because they have
a group of i think they have 5 000
members now so it's 160 000
mrr um because they have this
contingency of 5 000 like
really big shoe fanatics they can
probably give them special access to x y
and z they can do interviews with
special people
it's kind of interesting they raised two
million dollars uh recently
they say that they're adding 400 people
to what to their waitlist a day
i don't know if that's true but yeah
it's an interesting it's an interesting
space nonetheless what do you think of
that
uh i think you did good by passing on it
i think it's a cool business for the
person who owns it
it's definitely not a as constructor
right now that i don't see how that
becomes a
super large business worth investing in
worth why they need two million dollars
and how they're going to turn that into
you know a 200 million plus company i
don't really see that because
like we said communities themselves this
you know these chat groups don't scale
and um you know you're looking for
diehards who are going to pay
if you're paying 33 a month right like
you know that's more than
it's like you're providing more value
than amazon prime
you know what i mean like that's double
that's triple the price of amazon prime
and so you know you really have your
yeah the hardcores are going to go for
it
but also the more people you let in the
more people who all have access to the
same information the same tips the same
drops that they're trying to go buy
the harder it gets for you to actually
go buy anything that's valuable so
i don't really see how this becomes a
big big
venture scale business but i think it's
a great idea for somebody who's a big
shoe fanatic to create a community like
this i think that's an awesome lifestyle
business to to own
and uh like if that's your thing that's
great i love it
i agree with you um so let's talk about
three i can can i give you can i give
you two characteristics i think make it
work
one is high passion um and then the
second one
is the ability to make money on the
other side so this happens a lot with
stock trading groups
so um there are a bunch of stock tip
groups out there
where people are looking for additional
information and they want to be in a
group where the crowd is moving a
certain direction
you have this for sneaker heads you have
this for nfts right now collectibles
so so the key characteristic is it's not
just like
i'm a big fan of the you know the golden
state warriors so i'm going to join this
paid community for them
typically that doesn't work as well as
if i join this group
i'm going to get tools that are going to
help me make more money so it's a very
simple
money and money out calculation for
people and i think that's why it works
for sneakerheads
and it works for trading cards and it
works for crypto but it doesn't work as
well for like
you know people who just love gossip
girl yes so there's a few ways i think
that
if you're going to build this uh you've
got to think about the first is
the amount of money that your company is
going to make is exactly what you said
which is
it's directly in proportion to the
amount of revenue
that the uh attendees member can make
that so for example if you are
enthusiasts of rc cars
um well the equation here is
how much revenue the attendee or member
is going to make times how many there
are so members of people who like rc
cars
i have no idea i just made that up but
there's probably not that many of them
and because it's like a hobby that you
don't really make any money from you
probably cannot charge a lot for it
so that like probably won't be massive
that's not
i mean maybe you should do it but that
doesn't mean it's going to be
actually that big so that's the math
that you have to do which is
how much revenue is the member going to
make and how many of those potential
members are there
right or or the one like you said with
tiger 21 so tiger21 is actually like
that right
when you when you go and you hear
somebody's portfolio you're going to get
investment ideas
and even a single investment idea a
single like improvement to your
portfolio
if you have over 10 million dollars in
investable assets
one good idea is gonna more than pay for
the 30 000
of your membership excluding the friends
you'll make and the deals you'll do
together and that real estate thing
you'll buy together and all that good
stuff
so excluding all that now on the other
hand if you're looking at something like
um the aventa or whatever where it's
like
what is the cmo of nestle gonna do when
she meets the cmo
of delta like they're not gonna directly
get revenue out of it i don't think
that's why
i think it's like how hard were how hard
is it to accumulate this group of people
in a room so if it's really hard to
reach these people these are all high
value people then it's
the membership is worth the value of the
people in the group
so if it's just a bunch of sneaker head
buyers each individual member is
bringing zero like
clout to the table but if it's cmos of
different companies and it's about
how much clout do they each bring to the
table that's the value not so much how
much revenue they're gonna make
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be what i want to
i put my law in it like no days off on a
road let's travel never looking back
[Music]
uh